bonjour je m'appelle philippe vincent
choisi on est avec le premier michelin
trudeau derrière qui vécut de participer
à la cérémonie qui gagne à la bourse de
chine tirer partie de la visite
officielle de justin trudeau vietnam
c'est sa deuxième journée ici le but
premier c'est de renforcer les liens
économiques avec le vietnam y ait reçu
un accueil au palais présidentiel et à
la fin de la semaine il va se rendre au
sommet de l'apec le sommet de la
coopération des pays de l'asie du
pacifique
il va avoir deux dossiers importants qui
vont retenir l'attention du premier
ministre
le partenariat transpacifique donc on
part de cet accord de libre-échange la
douche pays - les etats-unis par contre
parce que depuis l'arrivée d'un autre
homme
les etats-unis ont décidé de se retirer
de cet accord de libre-échange là on va
voir qu'est-ce qui en est avec l'accord
des pays comme le japon qui aimeraient
avoir une entente de principe très
rapidement on va peut-être même une
annonce en marge du sommet de l'apec qui
vont aussi être question de la corée du
nord dans le train pour être au sommet
de l'apec la chine la russie aussi au
foirail à voir ces discussions donc sur
la menace nord coréenne et sur les
solutions aussi à trouver on veut front
commun du côté des états unis
alors on va suivre le premier ministre à
ce sommet et on va vous donner des
nouvelles
radio canada.ca